the Securities and Exchange Commission
filed separate civil lawsuits against
two major exchanges binance and coinbase
Caitlin ostroff covers cryptocurrencies
for the journal and explains the latest
showdown between Federal regulators and
the industry's biggest players
Finance is an international crypto
exchange that was founded in 2017 the
Securities and Exchange Commission sued
binance saying that it was operating an
illegal Securities Exchange in the U.S
and in doing so it sued not just
binance's U.S entity and its Global
entity but also Chiang Pang Xiao who is
the founder of binance
in its lawsuit the SEC said that binance
was offering tokens that were actually
Securities and that those were not
registered as such and because of that
binance was basically operating a sort
of black market for tokens that they
were not supposed to be allowed to let
users trade the SEC also really dug into
a lot of binance's operations two of the
firms that the SEC zeroed in on in the
binance complaint were called Merit Peak
and sigma chain these are two market
makers that were owned and operated by
Zhao binance's founder and CEO and the
SEC says that Sigma chain one of these
so-called Market making firms which buys
and sell cryptocurrencies was doing that
on binance us but trading a lot of the
same funds and so basically making it
look like there was a bunch more trading
than there actually was they also say
that there was the risk of funds being
co-mingled on binance us through the
Merit Peak entity and so they're saying
that because of those two entities users
weren't fully aware of what was
happening with their funds and what was
potentially happening in the background
binance has said that it intends to
defend the platform vigorously it has
vehemently denied that there was ever
any risk to customer funds that it
co-mingled assets
[Music]
not even a day later there was a
separate lawsuit that the SEC handed
down against coinbase the largest U.S
exchange in their lawsuit against
coinbase the SEC is saying that it also
traded assets that should have been
registered as Securities and because of
that coinbase was operating an illegal's
Securities Exchange as well
in response to the charges coinbase has
called for there to be more specific
legislation regarding cryptocurrencies
in Washington DC and has said that it's
going to continue to engage with
legislators to actually get that
legislation through Congress
[Music]
so for finance the SEC is seeking for
Zhao and his companies to not be able to
do business in the U.S it seems more
likely that this litigation is going to
drag out for a while unlike the
Department of Justice which can issue
criminal charges the SEC can really only
do civil charges at most you could be
looking at either a settlement or if a
judge rules in the sec's favor a
monetary fine
crypto has grown exponentially from when
it was created and worth basically
nothing in 2009 2010 to where we are now
where it's a one trillion dollar
industry the recent escalation and
enforcement from the agency has
certainly caught people's attention and
it does seem like they're starting to
really go after not just small companies
and projects as they have in the past
but really the biggest companies in the
ecosystem
foreign